we Define the physical as basically that  which has no phenomenal qualities that  which is exhaustively described in terms  of a list of abstract quantities such as  mass charge momentum spin geometric  relationships frequency amplitude and so  on and so forth and of course there is  nothing about these abstract quantities  in terms of which we could deduce the  quality of seeing a red apple or tasting  the apple or the quality of feeling a  bellyache or falling in love so by  definition we've turned these two  domains into incommensible domains one  is a given experience the qualities of  our inner life and the other is a  conceptual Creation in the physical  world